permesso scusi devo tornare qua mi
dispiace però devo devo devono andare
avanti non ho intenzione di rubarti
niente se tranquillo però devo per forza
proseguire come faccio a entrare la
dental troppo freddo provo di nuovo
ok ok ok ok ok ok
la chiave la chiave la chiave la chiave
la chiave la chiave la presa e l'ho
presa ho preso mi ha dato mercato
privato prelevato prelevato me ne vado
me ne vado mamma mia ragazzi mamma mia
mamma mia
la chiave storage che ho anche trovato
che ho trovato un pezzo di del cavaliere
provando a dare un'altra occhiata veloce
poi torno dentro nel caso ok ho trovato
un altro stato un altro quanto ok ok che
se questo non posso aprire lo
spostamento evo devo dove dove doveva
entrare dove tra rientrare tra ok
abbiamo visto dei mattoni prima per
sfondare devo provare a sfondare un
attimo quel muro se non riescono e ne
vado
dammi presso ott io mi sono sgolato
tutte le bottiglie uova un qualcosa da
tirare addosso
qualsiasi cosa ok un maiale riporto mi
porto un maiale ragazzi che aspettate
vado a è troppo pesante
ce la faccio scusate ok devo trovare
qualcosa da lanciare qualsiasi cosa
forza la scatola aprite
la missione fammi e chef non ci passo si
passa ci passò da babbo natale troppo
peso bene aperto il passaggio perché non
ci riesco a passato carri carta già
fatta
chievo dista maledetta porta non c'entro
più ok
raga non ci riesco ad andare nell'altra
stanza quindi prosegue di qua non è che
mi trovo di nuovo dietro quell affare no
me ne vado ma ne vado babbo favi leva le
tende
ok però andiamo di qua del maschi ok
cielo
cos'è questo sono caramelle e cnog to
caramel apples è questo il regalo che
devo portare uno dei bambini perfetto ce
l'ho già
devo spaccare i due denti davanti a
qualcuno questo me lo ricordo ancora è
l'unico regalo che riesco ancora a
ricordarmi tra l'altro diventato buio
pessi camera mia ragazza ha provato ad
accendere perché non si vede proprio
niente
ok permesso vago fa vide portare i
regali
ok questo era un altro babbo natale che
ha provato a portare i regali
io sono vengo in pace ragazzi
è chiuso bene perfetto una moda una
centrale o dentro però ok ok io me ne
vado di qui me ne voglio andare me ne
voglio andare ho sentito un rumore che
non mi è piaciuto per niente quindi me
ne vado vado me ne vado me ne vado me ne
vado me ne vado
me ne vado ok me ne vado me ne sto
andando stai tranquillo me ne sto
andando martello di thor cosa mi serve
ok io non aiuta ok è visibile su you
tube panici and now
ok se n'è andato se n'è andato
se n'è andato
grazie leprotto di merda dovevi farmi
spaventare in questo modo era necessario
cioè no perché prima che ho lanciato non
volevo partire il mare scusami però cosa
devo a questa ok si aprì ti prego amico
da resta ford ti prego perché non cos'è
you must say vi aggrada has been love
them in the sellers a long with other
servizi elisa che io ma scape ok
devo entrare nelle celle dove
provenivano quei versi molto vivaci lo
farò lo farò per te fratello mio
chi è il fratello di babbo natale non lo
so
ciao ragazzi ho paura e londra mattina e
mi sono preso due tra le parti più
grandi che io abbia mai preso nei
videogame in generale
ok vado fratello mio aiutami a portare i
regali ai bambini bisognosi
devo aprirla vero sono costretto ad
aprirla ok si è aperta la sola perfetto
nel ragazzo la cisco sesto rumore di
trascinamento
non sono io che cammino fratello mio
fratello mio salve sejna fi no fini
[Musica]
questo è il mio fra tutti questi
sarebbero i miei fratelli
a questo è mio fratello perfetto no
ragano ha capito cosa dovevo trovare qua
dentro c'è gli ormai sono più confuso
che altro non riesco a proseguire anche
questa è la gamba di mio fratello
mi sto pagando addosso ragazzi sentono
delle voci stupida
e poi che aiuto
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no i crediti
sono i cani di penombra
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
ma per oggi è veramente il cane di
penombra
ma che cosa ci fanno qui ormai ragazzi
mi perseguitano gli altri videogame
anche in amnesia prima svenderò ai cani
[Musica]
io mi vado
ha provato ne vado me ne vado me ne vado
bene vado nelle cose me ne vado batterie
batterie batterie ragazzi batteria una
delle più grandi dimensioni di non so
quale secolo però batteria
havana ve l'ho già prima non lo trovate
adesso ok bene facebook top anche nota
come sponsor questo nome
saresti tu mio fratello stefano
ok prova ad aprire series grande club
no no no no no no no
by stefano abbiamo vinto noi è un cane
posseduto ragazzi come mai non è venuto
qui a salvarti ok cattivo che ci sono io
per te
[Applauso]
ma solo la schiuma e grado
può fare più a portare sempre grosso
cosa vuoi che faccia per portarti sei
troppo grosso
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ok ma dovrà 96 grande arche ricordavo
più piccolo
non puoi camminare da solo vero
ascensore
ok perfetto ci ha appoggiato molto
delicatamente ok fratello mia ci siamo
stiamo per uscire
ok è tutto buio attiva perché stiamo
andando 18
non lo so ma sei pregato di
lynn iii piano terra non sostare davanti
alle porte
ok fatta tutto a posto
ok spero sia mollo blocking non è morto
di moschetti a new york stock grant
ok devo devo combattere il grinch
fantastico domandare a fermare il grinch
ok a buongiorno sa mica dirmi la
direzione di non ho fatto niente
mamma mia che che accoglienza di merda
ragazzi vanno di qua ok madonna che
istanza norme devo fantastico sexy
ladies mi serve non lo so neanche cosa
sto cercando ma vado avanti
ok ok c'è qualcosa qui sotto sinistra
destra mi ispira più la zisa
permesso nessuno ok raga non so cosa sto
cercato o cos'è che dolce bene sostanza
è qualcosa di inutile
non capisco il senso di stampa ragazzi è
ancora piena senza di quella dei troni e
il suse linux cosa che devo mettere il
mas place ha riacceso in decesso però se
sicar porta a moretti rosa sega nova
moletta e poi sigaretta la sigaretta mi
serviva non importa anche la rosa erano
i regali miei
ok
[Musica]
cos'è cioè fatemi capire è un
[Applauso]
[Musica]
fossero da ok fossero da ragazzi skyrim
ho imparato il fossero da come mossa
[Musica]
che cazzo ha paura di lui perché io cioè
il futuro da ok non posso usare siete
tristi perché perché ho ucciso il nostro
amico ho ricevuto una leva grazie
ragazzi sono passati dalla mia parte
va bene ragazzi vendicherò il vostro
amico a testa in giù avete capito
finalmente chi al babbo numero uno qui è
quindi
avete tutta la mia approvazione è
vendicato gol se l'amico state
tranquilli
ok ragazzi finalmente hanno capito chi è
il vero babbo qui e quindi niente number
one è sempre babbo favi quindi i regali
adesso penso siano compito mio bene non
so ancora cosa sto cercando ma devo
vendicare il loro amico in qualche modo
ok ok ok ok ok ok anche perché che le
scatole ai un ok sono stato videata
perché perché io ho lanciato la scatola
perchè gli ho lanciato la scatola perchè
perchè gli ho lanciato una scatola non
mi aveva visto sono thing is back in the
door
l'area è la leva serve per aprire la
porta però me ne serve un'altra cioè non
soltanto una finora forse è di questo mi
serve l'altra giusto che devo andare a
trovare l'altra leva nell'altra porta va
bene faccio un taglio finché non sono
arrivato davanti alla porta perché se no
è troppo lontano e non capisco perché
l'abbiano fatto cioè non ha senso face
la solita barba che mi lasciano come
regalo mi serve mi serve una leva
ragazzi assolutamente sono disperato non
so più come andare avanti
ai qua perfetto pick up picked up level
cioè io praticamente cioè io
praticamente ragazzi se noi lanciamo la
cassa quel deficiente ero già a posto
però va beh sono stupido pazienza sta
parte sempre chiusa per vado non è che
possa aprirla col fossero da ci riprova
ok niente
vado ad aprire finalmente sta porta qui
che penso sia la porta finale spero
perché veramente devo concluderlo al più
presto dice gioco permesso ok uomini
nudi volanti salve
niente regalo se sei sveglio mac shadow
and last words o lei e vermont idv al
studi vimark quindi vuoi darmi un
abbraccio vuoi abbracciarmi abbraccia
babbo favi questo è il tuo regalo per
quest'anno è però non riesco a
raggiungerti mischia ciò ecco ok con una
ritoccatina ogni tanto la mattina quando
ti svegli lavati la faccia perché sei
inguardabile comunque posso andare
dietro
no mi sa di no ok
cosa vuoi che faccia cosa devo fare
fossero da fossero da
ciao
ha senso se gioca ragazzi
buon natale a tutti anche se è passato
da una settimana buon 2013 la mappa è
stata fantastica
chiudiamo con una canzone di natale
arrangiata con la chitarra però buon
natale a tutti da babbo fai da te dopo
questo non metterò mai più un cappello
di babbo natale vita mia
[Musica]
ok basta la chiudo qui prima di rendermi
più ridicole solito spero che niente
questo video vi sia piaciuto
mettete mi piace alla pagina di facebook
trovati in descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi è la mappa
la trovati descrizione se volete
lasciare scaricarla comunque niente
lasciate un like al video se vi è
piaciuto
negli anticipi del prossimo video bella
ragazzi